Hey
y now time for reminders is done. Second
to last class. So hopefully your
projects are on their way to getting
done because the numbers are due on
Sunday. Last class is on Monday. project
is due at 5:00 p.m. on Monday. So today
I want to complete our discussion
evaluation. I know it's at the tail end
of the class. It it feels rushed and it
is rushed but I I want to talk at least
about the big pieces that go in. So the
on Monday we talked about the three big
drivers of your cash flows. Your revenue
growth which captures the growth part of
your company. Your operating margins
measures the profitability part. and
your sales to capital ratio which
measures how efficiently you deliver
growth. So let's focus on each revenue
growth. The higher the number the higher
your value is going to be holding all
else constant. The higher the operating
margins the better off your company is
the more valuable it becomes. Sales to
capital as you raise it you're reducing
how much you have to reinvest to get
growth. You're actually making your
company more valuable the higher sales
to capital.
So if you were designing a lab company,
the perfect
company, an amazing
company, you'd want it to have high
revenue growth. Obviously, you want to
have high margins because you want to
have growth and profitability, and you
want to have a high sales to capital. In
other words, this company's able to
deliver that growth with very little
reinvestment. If you get a chance, take
a look at the Mag Seven companies.
There's a reason they're the Mag Seven.
The reason they've got to where they are
is they've been able to pull off that
magic trick of high growth, high
profitability, and low reinvestment at
the same time. And they've done it at
scale. What that effectively means,
there are some companies that can do
this when they're $50 million companies,
but these are companies that have been
able to do it as 50 billion, 100
billion, 200 billion, 500 billion
companies. So when you look at your
company, that's what you're looking at.
Where does my company fall? And
obviously your company might not be that
special company. It might have a
weakness on one or more of those
dimensions. Chris I think is valing GM.
Right? Let's look at GM. Right? When you
tell the story for GM, what kind of
story is it going to be? Chris
one of
you know it's like you know somebody who
used to hit lots of home runs now
they're 41 42 43 maybe even 45. They're
still coming out to hit your best days
are behind you. But let's it's valuation
is all about the future. You can talk
about the greatness. I mean there was a
time when the entire US market as GM
goes so goes the economy used to be the
same right 60 70 years ago. That's no
longer the case. So Chris tell me your
story about GM in terms of revenue
growth. What do you see as the
possibility?
Is there a pathway to high growth for
for GM? What is what does it have to
pull off? What's uh what's if you were
playing poker and this had to be the the
draw you had to get. What would GM need
to do to get doubledigit growth for GM?
Double digit growth would be a miracle
because it's not been able to deliver.
what would it have to do
and enter that market and convince
people that buying a Chevy electric car
is as good as buying a Tesla or a BYD or
that's been the challenge for the last
15 years. I'm convinced that GM made a a
terrible mistake a decade ago when they
came out of the vault, which is a pretty
good electric
car and they called it the Chevy Volt. I
think that killed the car because you
walk into a showroom, you're buying an
electric car. You're no longer buying an
automobile. You're buying something like
an electronic device basically. You
don't want see the name Chevy attached
to it. You want to see some high-tech
name, something you've not seen before.
It's actually a problem that's not just
unique to GM. You see it at Ford. You
see it at Volkswagen. You see it at
Daimler. You see it at BMW. People don't
seem to be willing to buy electric cars
from legacy automakers because that name
becomes a problem rather than an
advantage. So let's say you map out at
least a pathway to survival. survival
for GM will require that they manage to
grow maybe even 3 to 5% which means that
their gas the the the the gas powered
card continued to and maybe protection
from competition might help them on this
dimension their margins were what do the
margins look like now Chris are they you
know they you have a sense of
that singledigit margins right now three
four 5% margins they struggle to even
deliver those margins Why? Cuz their
cost of goods sold are high. They
basically have very little pricing
power. This is a company where the room
for improvement is fairly limited. You
can cut cost, but there's only so much
you can do. So, as you tell your story
for GM, it's going to be low growth,
potentially slight improvement in
margins. The one saving grace they might
have if you're not going to go full
scale into electric cars, and even that
might be might be an issue, is they
don't have to build more. They have
enough capacity to build more cars, but
they'll have to retool it. So, the
reinvestment will have to be to take
their capacity and those factories and
Flint and, you know, wherever else they
have them and try to convert them to
make the cars for the future. You can
already see this is not going to be an
upbeat story, right? This is not going
to be a story that's going to soar and
give you the kinds of numbers you would
like it to
give. Let's pick a different company.
So, Chris, the spotlight's off you. So
you don't have to worry,
right? Kelly, you're valuing Lululemon,
right?
Lululemon has had again a high growth
past and now we're approaching a point
where you're getting more competition.
The apparel business is getting more. So
if you're looking at growth, it would,
you know, I'm sure Lululemon would love
to grow at double digit. They have plans
and they're trying, but it's going to be
a tough haul. Maybe you are upbeat and
you can you buy into the management
story and you give them growth. It's not
going to be 50% growth. Maybe it's 12 13
14 8 N 8 N. So basically you're looking
at moderate growth. Why? Because they're
already a big company in a business
that's
comparative. And then you look at
margins. Their brand name has allowed
them to deliver pretty reasonable
margins. That's held up even as their
growth has come down. And there the
question is will the brand name continue
to hold up?
Apparel brand names know do decay over
time. You can sometimes rediscover them.
Crocs is a good example of a company
that lost its brand name discovered it.
But that's going to be part of your
story. And the reinvestment here is
going to be strange. It's not in
factories per se. It's in the brand
name. It's in the advertising they're
doing is part of their reinvestment as
well. Let's do one final example and
then we'll kind of move on to terminal
value. I know this there's a group doing
restaurants. I would pick is anybody
from that group
here? And which one are you doing? Shake
Shack. Shake Shack. And you know I Caba
is probably part of that group. Shake
you know the cheese I think Cheesecake
Factory. Cheesecake. Chipotle.
No. Yeah. Let's throw it into the mix as
well. No Chipotle. You can throw in
McDonald. I mean there are only so many
places you can go in restaurants, right?
Most of these are us get the bulk of
their revenues from the US. So let's
start by looking at the overall
restaurant business in the US. You ask
if I asked you to describe that
business, you know what what do you
think about overall restaurant business
in the US? I mean it's data like the
mature US market is pretty saturated,
right? I mean none of us ever complains
I can't find a restaurant. I drive by
seven restaurants to get to one. This is
an incredibly saturated market at least
in urban areas, maybe even in suburban
areas. So it is that's going to be a
challenge. So if you're valing Chipotle,
which has a significant market share,
it's clear that you're not going to be
able to open 20% more stores every year.
Those days are done. But you have Cava
in your group, right? What's the
advantage Cava has? It's a young small
company with the potential for growth.
Much of its growth is going to come from
where? taking market share away from
other fading
restaurants. The Cheesecake Factory is
probably in
trouble because you eat the pasta primma
vera at the Cheesecake Factory. I think
it's 2,200 calories. So, this is
basically, you
know, you know, it's 2,200 calories for
the vegetable pasta. I don't know how
they even I looked at and say, how do
you get 2,200 calories into this dish?
But they manage it. It's amazing.
Cheesecake Factory might be the loser.
Cabba might. So even within your group,
you'll be anointing winners and losers.
And essentially that's going to show up
in the
story. The margins at restaurants are
determined by what? What are the
drivers? The cost of food obviously,
right? And that's that could come under
pressure. If you're getting avocados
from Mexico and you have to you have to
pay extra for them. But the bigger cost
is that cost of the people who work at
your restaurants. And with the pressure
on minimum wages going up because you
know you can't be paying
$7.50 your your cost structure is under
pressure. You might be able to pass it
through to your customers. That's what
they're doing. But the business is under
stress and that's going to show up in
your stories. Doesn't mean that these
companies can't be worth a lot but
they're fighting a headwind.
So one final example, Palunteer, right?
I know three people in this class who
picked Palunteer right now high growth
company or low growth company it grow
about 30% last year right there margins
are right
now they're pretty
low. I think they made what 2% 3%
margins last year or know it was pretty
it was in the single digits which
doesn't look right right but at the same
time remember the young company that's
scaling up as you scale up these margins
have much more potential to improve much
more so than restaurants because the
unit economics we talked about work in
their favor because once you've got the
infrastructure set up selling that extra
service selling that extra data product
cost you almost
nothing. So if you're valing Palunteer,
you take your existing margin whether
it's 5 or 6% and you push it up to 30 35
40% which is typical of software
companies. You have room on the
upside and that's going to essentially
allow them to kind of grow their profits
at a rate which is disproportionately
large relative to the revenue. They're
going after a big market. The primary
market is the defense budgets of you
know so I think this year it's going to
be a trillion dollars. they're not going
to get the entire trillion. So you'll
have to make a judgment on what
percentage of that will go to to to data
software and Palanteer will and the
advantage of being in that business is
incredibly sticky which is once you get
that defense contract the defense
department is not going to cut you off
very quickly because it's so difficult
to
disentangle and find another company in
the mix.
That's what I mean about storytelling
and numbers is as you think through your
revenue growth margins and if you ask me
if and you know the question that's
going to keep popping up as you come up
with these numbers. How do I know I'm
right? I'll save you the trouble. You're
definitely
wrong. In fact, you're going to be wrong
100% of the time. Why? Because you're
trying to forecast the future. Nobody
knows how the restaurant business in the
US is going to evolve precisely. You're
making your best estimate. your value of
the company's based on the best
estimate and you follow it by investing
based on that story. So I'm going to
finish off the the picture with my
valuation of BU in 200
2014. I gave them pretty healthy revenue
growth. Do you know where this revenue
growth is coming from? It's coming from
the fact that China in 2014 was still
growing at 8 n 10%. you are the leading
search engine in the fastest growing
online retail market in the world. It's
going to give you some tailwind the
online advertising 25% and if you look
at the revenues in year 10 they're
almost six times larger than the
revenues now because it's a big market
and it's growing those of you valuing
Indian companies or Chinese companies
this is an advantage you have over
valuing an East European company the
market itself is so big that if your
company can find a pathway it can
deliver that growth for the margins the
margins are skyhigh high and think of
why online advertising unit economics
are absolutely insane right you sell
that extra ad there's no additional cost
so just like Google their margin in fact
their margins are higher than Google's
margins close to 50%. I do think they
will come under pressure because they
compete against
giants. Tencent, JD, Alibaba all trying
to come after that same market because
they all want Alibaba ultimately is an
advertising company as well. It's not
like Amazon a retail company. It's an
advertising company. It faces
competition. So I think the margins will
come down and my argument for margins
coming down is going to be increased
competition in this market.
Reinvestment in this company is going to
be strange, right? It's going to be
technology, R&D, it's acquisitions. So
that number you see under reinvestment
reflects that. But here I'm assuming
that the history of reinvestment is
going to be a good predictor of the
future. Not always a good assumption,
but in this case it worked. I got my
reinvestment for the next 10 years.
Revenue growth, margin, sales to
capital. The 2.64 gives me my free cash
flow to the firm. The nice thing about
having just three levers is you don't
get distracted easily, right? Everything
has to flow through those three
levers. Any questions on the on making
these operating
assumptions? I I do want to talk your
question. I thought you had a question.
Okay. I want to talk about a special
case though if you're valing a mature
company. And I did look through the the
the master list this morning and a lot
of you are valuing mature companies.
Companies like Coca-Cola, Craft Times,
Manderlay, right? Mature companies.
What's they've settled in, their margins
are stable. Their returns and capital
are pretty predictable. You know what
their competitive advantage? It's a
brand name or something that is enduring
there. You can actually use a shortcut
to get expected growth. You can tie the
expected growth to what the company is
reinvesting and how well it's
reinvesting. I talked a little bit about
this at the start of the discussion of
growth. You're saying what do you mean
you know how much it's reinvesting and
how well it's reinvesting. Let me give
you let me give you measures of what I'm
going to do to get those measures of how
much you're reinvesting and how well
you're reinvesting. It depends again on
which metric I'm looking at. If I want
to predict growth in earnings per share
for a mature company, and only for a
mature company, things have settled in,
I'm going to take your retention ratio.
Remember the payout ratio we talked
about when we talked about dividends,
payout ratio of 40%, you have a
retention ratio of 60%. So that's what
you're reinvesting. And I'm going to
multiply by your return in
equity. If you're looking at a bank,
which is where I would use this most
likely, JP Morgan has a return in equity
of close to 18%.
It has a retention ratio of about 50%.
It retains about 50% of its net income.
50% of 18% gives me an expected growth
rate of 9%. And at least for the near
term, that is what I'd expect the growth
in earnings per share to be for JP
Morgan. If I'm looking at free cash flow
equity, I'm going to use slightly more
refined measures of what I'm reinvesting
and what my return in equity is going to
be. Here I'm going to look at the equity
reinvestment rate. The percentage of my
net income that I have to come up with
as an equity investor. Net cap exchange
in working capital. Net of the debt that
I use. My equity reinvestment rate is
going to capture what I
reinvest. It could come like Coca-Cola.
Its equity reinvestment rate is about
15%. It reinvests about 15% of its net
income back. Not much, right?
But if you look at the return equity
here, I'm going to focus on the return
equity on non-cash assets. What does
that mean? I'm going to take your book
equity, net out the cash because that's
a separate asset. Take your net income,
net out the interest income from cash,
and I'm going to come up with what's
called a non-cash return equity. It's
what I'm making on the equity that is
not cash. I think uh Warren Buffett
calls this tangible book value of
equity. Basically, the book value of
equity in your operating assets. You
know what that number looks like for
Coca-Cola? It's about
60%. When you get these really high
returns in invested capital and returns
and equity, which some of you are
already dealing with a few companies,
it's always worth stopping and asking
why why is Coca-Cola's return equity so
high, Kendry? What's what's what's
keeping the return equity so elevated
for
Coca-Cola? That's a insanely high return
equity, right? 60%. Much higher than the
cost of equity. Yes.
pay a lot of dividends.
Lead me through how paying a lot of
because their bank banks pay a lot of
dividends. Their returns in equity are
in the toilet, right? Utilities play a
pay a lot of dividends. They have like
like 11 12% returns in
equity. So, but I can understand a
mechanism by by which dividends what is
what do dividends affect that show up in
your return equity? They they drive down
retain earnings. They drive down retain
earnings. So, lower book equity. In
fact, it's not dividends that usually
cause spikes in return equity. It's big
buybacks. Buybacks are huge. You can do
Home Depot as a not meaningful return
equity. Still, I think because they
bought back so much stock, the book
equity went negative. So, that's almost
a cosmetic pushing up of return equity.
It's not because you're taking great
projects, you've lowered the book
equity. Now, Coca-Cola's return equity
predates their buybacks and dividends.
So it's not the low book value of equity
that's causing the high return equity.
It's high net income, right? So which
comes from some economic reason, some
competitive
advantage. And already we're on to for
Coca-Cola, it's brand name, but even
with a brand name, it's co its return
equity is much higher than Pepsi's
return in equity. And there you have to
look at the difference in two companies.
If you're a beverage company, you got a
brand name, which is this intangible
huge return. But you also have to have
bottlers, people who make the Coca-Cola
about 40 years ago spun off its
bottlers. That's a separate company. So
when you buy Coca-Cola, you're buying
just the syrup. It's about as pure a
play on brand name as you can get. So
you have a 60% return equity. Let's
bring the two numbers together. I said
their equity reinvestment rate is only
like 10, 12, 15%. But the return equity
is
60%. Even if you reinvest only 10% of
your money back, if you get a 60% return
equity, you can get a 6%
growth. And then there's a final measure
of metric, and that's to look at
operating income. In operating income,
your growth is captured by looking at
your reinvestment as a percentage of
your after tax operating income you put
back into the
business. Remember for Disney that
number was about 54%.
I took the net capex and change in
working capital divided by after tax
operating income. They're reinvesting
about
54%. Historically, they've earned a
return on capital of about
12.6%. Now, this is a reach. But if I
assume they can maintain those numbers,
54% reinvestment rate, 12.6% return on
capital, my growth rate becomes almost a
given. It's 12% times 54%. It's about
six 6 and
a2%. You know why engineers and
quantitative people like this approach?
Because what does it take away the the
So what do you no no longer have to do
if you just have to multiply numbers to
get the expected growth rate. You don't
have to forecast future
growth. So thank god I don't have to
forecast future growth. It comes with a
price though because you are making an
assumption that things have settled in.
I can't do this if I'm valuing
palenteer. things haven't settled in and
for most companies is pro probably not a
safe assumption to make and that's why I
push you down the revenue growth the
margin the reinvestment assumption but
this is going to be hanging out in the
background saying can I come in now can
I come in now because at some point in
time I am going to use this to kind of
simplify my life because it basically
ties together growth return on capital
and reinvestment if you're doing free
cash flow of the firm or growth return
on equity and equity equity reinvestment
if you're looking at cash flows to
equity. So that's the extended
discussion of growth. Let's talk about
using this to get the growth rate for my
companies. I told you I was I was valing
Deutsche Bank with a dividend discount
model in January 2008. At that time the
return in equity was
19.45%. And the retention ratio was
about 67%. This is just before the 2008
crisis when banks were at at their peaks
in terms of how much money they were
making. So in 2018, if I left those
numbers as they were, I'm sorry, 2008,
if id left the numbers as they were, the
expected growth rate I'd have given
would have been sky-high almost 13%. 67%
retention ratio times a 19% return
equity. And you can see already the
danger I've exposed myself to, right? I
took a peak here which was 2007. I've
essentially assumed that this is how the
world is going to look from now on. I'm
going to overestimate
growth. I don't know how you feel about
2024 numbers for your company. But if
you feel your 2024 numbers are
unsustainably high, your company had a
really good year. There's a common sense
fix to that, right? Rather than look at
the most recent year, you look at
averages over time. Averaging is just a
way of dealing with the fact that
numbers jump around. Numbers jump around
saying, "I don't want to use last year's
numbers. I want to smooth things up." If
you look at the average return on equity
over the previous 5 years, you get more
reasonable numbers. 11.8% return equity
and a retention ratio of closer to
46%. In valuing Deutsche, that's the
growth rate I use. It's a 5.4% where I
said things are going to revert back to
the norm. And in hindsight, I even with
those normalized numbers, I
overestimated growth for Deutsche
because in the 2008 crisis hit, the
returns in equity
collapsed. And if you ask me, why didn't
you forecast the 2008 crisis in March of
2008? If I could do that, why would I be
valuing
banks? I'd be selling short on the S&P
500, heading out to, you know, the hills
and waiting it out. I mean, the fact is
things will change. you value Marriott
in 2019 and I pick on you for not seeing
CO coming, one of two things is going to
be true. Either you saw CO coming, in
which case you're going to be in front
of a congressional committee sooner or
later, or you didn't see CO coming,
which is where most of us were, right?
It's not fair to go back and say, you
know, why didn't you see something
coming when nobody saw it coming? You
have to do your best to be proactive,
but things will happen.
So this shortcut works only if you're
willing to make that steady state
assumption for Tata Motors. Again I
normalize things. So I looked at the if
you look at the the equity reinvestment
rate 88%. You say why are they
reinvesting so much? It's actually
unusually high for for an automotive
company but they happen to be an Indian
automobile company. So you got that
factor of growth coming in and
reinvestment being high. The return in
equity was actually
43%. And sometimes when you look at the
numbers, your reaction is I don't
believe these
numbers because you multiply those
numbers the expected growth you get is
23 to 38%. Even if you normalize
things, there are times where you have
to step back and say, I can compute a
return capital for my company. I can
comput a reinvestment rate, but they're
coming from accounting data. I don't
think I can base my valuation on those
numbers. In which case, go back to
estimating revenue, growth, margins, and
reinvestment just like we did because
that forces you to go and think about
business models and doesn't put you at
the mercy of computations of accounting
return on capital and reinvestment rate.
And finally for Disney, I did use their
return capital. Oh, one side note this.
When you look at equity cash flows and
you look at return equity, a company can
get a high return equity in one of two
ways. It can take great projects, right?
The other is the real estate way, which
is to take average projects and lever up
to the hilt. It's been the classic way
in which return equity in real estate
has been pumped up. And the reason
return equity will increase as you take
leverage is you borrow money and you get
a tax advantage in the debt. It might
cost you five or 6% to borrow money even
if it's high cost debt. If you take a
building or a property that makes a
return of 10% you claim the difference
as an equity investor. So as you borrow
more and more money your return in
equity will rise which means in our
models you'll end up giving higher
growth to companies that use more
leverage. Right? Seems like a free
lunch. What's the catch here? You have
higher growth coming from higher
leverage. But you value the equity in
the company. What do we use? a cost of
equity. And what drives the cost of
equity? A beta. And what drives a beta?
The unlevered beta of the business and
your debt to equity. So what one hand
will give you with higher growth. The
other hand will take away with higher
risk. The net effect could actually be
negative. And in my view, a lot of
attempts to push up leverage end up
lowering value rather than increasing
value because the risk effect can
dominate whatever you gain in terms of
returns. So as you look at the
accounting returns, take a look at where
the returns are coming from. Are they
coming from great projects? They're
coming from leverage because the effect
will be very different. So if you take
two firms here which have the same
return equity, company A got its return
equity by taking great
projects. This is the Apple Microsoft
way. They took great projects, have high
returns and equity. Company B had a high
return equity because it took a 12%
return on capital, used a lot of debt
and took that difference and pushed into
the return equity. So they both look the
same in terms of return equity, but I
will treat them differently in terms of
risk because company B is riskier than
company A because it use so much
leverage. It's one more reason why we
went through that torture of unlevered
betas and levered betas. I know it sound
I mean felt like we were spending way
too much time there. It's to make it
clear that le debt is a double-edged
sword. It can help you. It can push up
your growth. It can make your return
equity great. But you got to walk in
with eyes open which is also makes your
equity riskier. It pushes up your cost
of equity and the net effect can be
negative. Finally for Disney the
reinvestment rate the most recent year
was 54%. Their return on capital was
12.6%. Those were numbers we the return
on capital in particular we we computed
in the investment return section to look
at how good their investments were. And
here again, if I if you ask me why is
Disney's return on capital
12.6%. I'm going to talk about its
competitive advantages. It's its
branding. The fact that you can take it
back to the mouse, right? That that
mouse has generated more value for
Disney than pretty much anything Disney
has done as a
company. There's a brand name, but brand
names can decay. There was a time in
2004 when Disney's return on capital
dropped to its cost of capital. that was
at the absolute bottom of Michael
Eisner's stint at Disney. He'd actually
decayed the brand name enough that the
brand name value had gone away. It was
recreated. But there should be an order
of warning for Bob Iger. This is not
permanent. You have a brand name. You
have an advantage. But you can dissipate
it if you're not focused or you do
things that actually reduce the value of
that brand name. So at every stage when
you look at a number, stop and ask the
question, where is that number coming
from? What's driving that number? So
based on the 54% reinvestment rate, the
12.6% return on capital, my expected
growth for Disney is 6.8%. So let's we
let's see where we are with cash flows
can either be cash flows to equity
defined narrowly as dividends or free
cash or equity which is potential
dividend. Cash flow to the firm is a
pre-debt cash flow. So the difference is
you start with after tax operating
income, you subtract out reinvestment,
you come up with a free cash flow of the
firm on the discount rate. Your choice
on cash flows will drive your choice of
discount rate. If you decided to go the
dividends free cash flow equity route,
your discount rate has to be a cost of
equity. If you decide to go the free
cash flow to the firm route, your
discount rate has to be a cost of
capital. On growth, always start with
the generic approach, revenue growth,
margins, reinvestment. But if you have a
special case of a company that you think
has settled debt, margins are stable,
returns on capital are pretty
predictable, then you can use the
shortcuts to get the expected growth
rate, your reinvestment rate, and your
return capital. Which leaves us with one
final big number, cash flows, growth,
discount
rates. We need
closure. Why do we need closure? I mean,
let's step back. The value of an asset
is the present value of the expected
cash flows in the asset, right? That's
that's pretty much all of this
class. So if I gave you a 10-year asset,
what are you going to do? You're going
to project the cash flow for the next 10
years. Get a risk adjusted discount
rates. And that's what we did in capital
budget. Come up with the present value.
20-year cash flows. Same process, 20
years, but you're trying to value an
entire company now, right? You're not
valuing a project. And the difference
with the company is it has a portfolio
of projects and it can keep recreating
itself by adding projects. Disney in
2025 doesn't look like the Disney in
1957 because over time it's added, it's
augmented, it's changed as a company.
And already you can see the mathematical
challenge. If you open up a corporate
charter, it tells you when a company was
founded, but it doesn't tell you when
the company will be warmed up. So at
least in theory what can happen your
cash flows can keep going and going
forever. That's a challenge we face
right? We cannot forecast cash flows
forever. So we're looking for closure a
point of time where we stop. But you
can't just stop and ignore all cash
flows after that because there's still
value when you stop. That's where the
terminal value comes in. The terminal
value allows you to put closure by
looking at what happens after year five
year 10. You say I'm tired of estimating
cash flows. The terminal value captures
what those cash flows will be forever.
I'm going to give you the standard way
of estimating terminal value, but I'm
also going to ask some what if questions
about the terminal value because I think
the 21st century company is putting
pressure on how we think about terminal
value. The standard way in which
terminal value is computed is by
assuming that at some point in time in
the future. What point in time will vary
across companies. For Palenteer, it
might be 20 years from now. For Mandlay,
it might be right now. You might already
be there. You're at a point where your
growth rate is sustainable
forever. At what level? If it's forever,
it has to be less than or equal to the
growth rate of the economy in which you
operate. Right? And this is not a
financial argument. It's a mathematical
argument cuz think of what will happen
to a company that grows at a rate faster
than the economy forever. Ultimately,
it'll become the economy that'll blow
the whole process up. So, it comes with
a cap. So, when you tell me your company
isn't stable growth, you're essentially
telling me that this company is a mature
company. It's a company growing at a
rate less than the economy. That's why I
said Mandlay might already be there. It
might be a company where you're not
going to have high growth. I know Levi
Strauss struggling. You know you're
doing it. Are you doing Levi Strauss?
They might have some growth. I think
Asia is a market that they're going
after, but that growth is not going to
be for very long before they settle into
stable
growth. Let's talk about the terminal
value because it's a terrifying number.
It's where the most damage is done in
valuation. Let's start with the pure
math. When you do a discounted cash flow
valuation, cash flows in year 1 2 3 4 5.
you get to your your five and you say
I'm going to compute a terminal value
that terminal value number is going to
be huge relative to your cash
flows and there are there's a mythology
around that that number and how big it
can get and why your in the rest of your
valuation is pointless because it's all
driven by the terminal value. So, what
I'm going to do is focus in on the
terminal value. Talk about things, guard
rails you can put to keep your terminal
value from running away with your
valuation because you can do a lot of
work getting your year 10 cash flows
from now through 10. But if you screw up
on the terminal value, it ruins all that
work you did. So, here
are the mythologies around terminal
value and the reality as I see it that
you got to bring in. The first myth is
that the only way to estimate terminal
value and I blame people like me who
write books is to use that perpetual
growth model.
Right? But I and you look at the
perpetual growth model, you look at so
nobody lasts forever. That's true,
right? So why do we use a perpetual
growth model? Because you last for 60 70
80 years using forever is going to give
you a reasonable approximation of that
number. It's a convenience assumption.
But let's say you're looking at a
company that you don't think will last
for 60, 70 or 80 years. Last for only 25
years using a perpetual growth model is
going to overestimate your terminal
value. There you get to year five or
year 10, you might say, look, I know I
don't want to estimate cash flows any
anymore, but I don't think this company
will last forever. You can actually
estimate it terminal value using a
finite growth period, a 15-year period.
get the present value, the cash flows.
People seldom do it, but I think we need
to think about it. And here's
why. Let's take the classic 20th century
company, GE. It was actually a 19th
century company. It was founded in 18 I
think it was listed in
1890. Grew through the 20th century. Got
a wave of life after, you know, Jack
Welch came in in the 80s, kind of
rediscovered growth. briefly the largest
market cap company in the world around
20201 and in this century it completely
collapsed. Now all that's left of it is
debris, right? Pieces of it hanging out
all over the place. But it had a
glorious life
1890 to
2025 135 years. You can take GM, no take
it through its life.
Ford companies that last 80, 90, 100 and
those were the classic 20th century
companies. In contrast, let's take
Yahoo, which I'm going to call a 21st
century company even though it started
in the 1990s, right? Founded in 1992 by
those two Yahoos from Stanford. They
called themselves Yahoos basically. I
think they took it as a joke, but the
company wasn't a joke.
It built up from nothing to a hundred
billion in seven years. By
1999, Yahoo was a hundred billion dollar
company. What took G, GM, and Ford
decades to do, Yahoo did in seven years.
This is amazing, right? They scaled up
fast. How long did they last at the
top? You can date their start of decline
to Google being listed in 2004. So they
had a they had a brief window where they
were dominant 5 years and then they went
down and they just didn't go down. They
just collapsed. By 2012 this company was
a shadow of what it had been. It search
engine basically was decaying and dying.
Marissa Meyer was brought in to turn the
company around. A completely hopeless
exercise at that point in time because
there was nothing to recover. And by
2015 the company was done. I mean, if
you want to get even briefer life cycle
story, think about
Blackberry. Started by Canadian
entrepreneurs, takes off in the 90s.
Everybody had Blackberry thumb. This was
the Steve Jobs gets up with that black
turtleneck, introduced the iPhone, the
Blackberry's dead in seven years, 16,
17, 18
years. The typical 21st century company
doesn't look like the typical 20th
century company. We're on Zoom. recorded
on Zoom. I like Zoom. It's an amazing
platform. Do I think it's going to be
around 70 years from now? I don't think
so. I think this is a platform that'll
peak. I mean, it scales up quickly.
It'll it'll have a period at the top.
And 20 years from now, I seriously doubt
that we'll be on Zoom, that this is a
company that has a much shorter life
cycle. You see where I'm going, right?
Much of what we know in business, not
just in valuation, was written in the
20th century. It was written for the
20th century company and one of those
things was terminal value use a
perpetual growth model. Why? Because
companies typically last if they succeed
80, 90, 120 years. But what if companies
they succeed last only 25 years? I think
you should at least think about the
possibility that you can use a 15-year
growing annuity or a 10-year growing
annuity to get the terminal value rather
than a perpetuity. So that's the first
myth. You you have to use that R minus C
and a perpetual growth model. Not true.
Second, and this is this drives me
crazy, is there are people who look at
that perpetual growth model and say I
could get an infinite value. You see how
what's in the numerator? Your expected
cash flow, what's in the denominator, R
minus G, right? Let's say your R is
about 8%. Which is, you know, not
unusual cost to cap for a mature
company. Your growth rate is 3%. Well,
you're okay. Then if you make the three
into four, four into five, five into
six. Do you see what's going to happen
as the growth rate moves towards the
discount rate, you're what I call Buzz
Light here valuations. You're going to
infinity and beyond, right? Because
you're going to keep going through. I've
seen people send me valuations of growth
companies. Now, I remember getting a
valuation of Microsoft where the the
person sending the email said, "I'm
using your terminal value model to value
Microsoft and I'm getting a negative
value. what's wrong with your model? So,
I took a look at what he'd done. He'd
assumed a 12% growth rate forever for
Microsoft and his discount rate was 8%.
And I said, there's nothing wrong with
the model. There's something wrong with
you. Right? You assume a 12% growth rate
in perpetuity. What kind of universe is
this even possible? If you obey the
basic rule that your growth cannot
exceed the growth rate of the economy,
you will never get a terminal value. you
will not even get close to it because
your discount rates will have that risk
premium and in fact in the spreadsheet
that I have I constrain your growth rate
to the risk-free rate. Why? Because I
don't want you to go above the risk-free
rate. The risk-free rate is in fact a
decent proxy for nominal growth. So I
look at your risk-free rate and say hey
you go above that number you've broken a
cardinal rule in valuation. You're
saying can I go a little bit above that
number? No. This is one of those things
you don't want to mess with cuz once you
start tweaking that growth rate, you've
lost control of the valuation. Third
misconception about valuation is that
the growth rate you use in your terminal
value is the big assumption you make in
valuation. And mathematically it looks
like it is, right? So let's say you have
a company valued using a 3% growth rate
in forever. Changing the 3% to 4% looks
like a freebie, right? 3% to 4% should
push up the terminal value. What am I
missing, Derek? When I do that, when I
change the growth rate, what else should
change? But but at a 4%, it' still be a
higher value, right? So, I'm discounting
still a higher
value. But when I change the growth from
3 to 4%, what else needs to change?
What's in my numerator? Expected cash
flow. How do I get expected cash flows?
I take operating income and I subtract
out reinvestment. Right? Originally, I'd
reinvested enough to create a 3% growth
rate. Now I'm going to go for a 4%
growth rate. Your numerator also has to
change because I have to reinvest. I'll
give you the simple rule. If you're
earning roughly your costed capital,
which a lot of companies do in steady
state, changing your growth rate will
have no effect on value. None. Because
when you change the growth rate, your
cash flows will drop by roughly the same
amount. It's like taking zero net
present value projects. That's what
earning your cost of capital is. And
remember what we said about zero net
present value projects. You can take a
thousand of them. 1,000 times 0 is still
zero. So the growth rate is not the big
assumption. It's what you assume about
returns and capital forever. And that's
part of your
story. Most companies will tend to see
their returns on capital fade to their
cost of capital. You're valuing an
automobile company, a steel company, you
know, an
airline. I'll almost guarantee you that
in steady state, you'd be lucky to earn
your cost of capital, your return. So
there the growth assumptions are not
big. You're valing
Coca-Cola, you have an issue on your
hand, right? Brand names last a long
time. They're not going to go away after
year 10. Same thing with a company like
Palanteer. You built a platform, you got
products, you got a sticky business.
Those companies, you might leave the
return on capital above the cost of
capital, but your story needs to tell me
why. This is why I'm doing because that
drives
that. Can your growth rate be negative?
Right. Where's the Nokia thinkers
or you selling Chevron,
right? Oil
company. First to begin with, if you're
a commodity company, can you grow
forever? You run the commodity runs out,
right? So already you've got a physical
limit on how much you can get out. But
there's a second issue which is to the
extent that you've got climate change
and issues from fossil fuel from that.
Over time, you can make an argument that
if you're valing Chevron that you get to
year five or year 10 that your growth
rate beyond year five or 10 is going to
be minus 3% here. Think am I allowed to
do that? Absolutely. You'reing a tobacco
company. You might be in negative growth
right now and your growth rate can be
negative forever. What do you
effectively have with a negative growth
rate in perpetuity? Your company grows
for the next 10 years. it hits its peak
and then after that the company gets
smaller over time and disappears which
actually makes more sense if you think
about what happens to corporate life
cycles across
time. Now when I talk to people or
appraisers I often ask them the question
have you ever used a negative growth
rate in perpetuity? None of them ever
have. Maybe you should start thinking
about that at least for a subset of
companies. And finally, I have and there
actually, you know, valuation standards
and I think in Germany the terminal
value is not supposed to exceed 75% of
you. Stupidest rule ever. And here's
why. Will the terminal value be a high
percentage of your value today,
Leon? Yes. It's going to be 75 80 85%.
And that freaks people out, right? 85%
of my value is coming from the terminal
value and then you make that leap which
I think is a is a bad leap but you say
if 85% of my value is coming from the
terminal value what does it matter what
I assume over the next 10 years why is
that a bad
leap it's true mathematically 80% of
your what drives you terminal value your
cash flow in year 11 right what drives
your cash flow in year 11 your earnings
in year 11 how do you get to earnings in
year 11 your revenue growth and margins
over the next 10 years you play with
those growth rates and margins your
terminal value is going to be affected
as well. So just because the terminal
value is a high percentage of the value
today doesn't mean you shouldn't be
paying attention to your next 10 years.
In fact, you should be paying a lot more
attention. Second, think about why the
terminal value is such a high percentage
of your value
today. For those of you who held a stock
for seven, eight, nine, 10 years, five
or even five years, let's say it's a
good stock, stock you bought at a low
price that's gone up. Anybody want to
volunteer a stock they've invested in?
This is your bragging right chance. Make
up the fact you bought Invidia in 2018.
Act like you did, even if you didn't,
right? So, let's say you bought Invidia
in 2018, right? You had a good run,
great run, an amazing run. But I want
you to think about how you've made money
on the stock. Did he get a lot of
dividends over those seven years?
No. You made your money from price
appreciation. Until you sell, you're not
going to collect it. Which means the
bulk of your value comes from when you
sell the stock and you get the price
appreciation. You know what the terminal
value is? It's the standin for that
price
appreciation. So when you buy a high
growth company, when you buy a mature
company, even Proctor and Gamble or
Coca-Cola, maybe 70% of your value comes
from the terminal value. When you buy a
palenteer 120% of your value might come
from the terminal value. You can say how
can it be more than 100%. If you have
negative cash flows you need to cover
with new stock issues. You will end up
with delusion happening over that
period. There is no rule you can adopt
for terminal value. It's going to vary
across companies being higher for growth
companies and lower for mature companies
but it'll never be 30% of terminal value
of your your value today. That doesn't
make any sense. You buy a bond, maybe
you can get the bulk of your value from
the coupons, but you buy stock for a
very different reason, for the price
appreciation, which makes it terminal
value the biggest number. So there's a
lot of mythology. You're going to run
into this mythology at work because
people come in with these preconceptions
about terminal value. In fact, this
becomes the reason they don't do
discounted cash flow valuations. They
say the discounted cash flow, it's so
flawed. The terminal value is so
subjective. It drives my valuation. Not
true. But it gives them an excuse to go
out and use some stupid EV to sales
multiple to attach a pricing to the
company and keep going. And I'm not
willing to let them use this escape
hatch. You don't want to do intrinsic
value. At least be honest and upfront.
Say, I don't care about value. I'm a
trader. I want to buy at a low price,
sell at a high price. Then we can have a
honest, but don't hide behind terminal
value being the reason you don't want to
do a DCF value.
Yes,
yeah,
you can do just terminal value right
now. That's why I said one delay. You
can actually take the stable growth
model. Just make sure that the base
numbers are numbers you can live with,
right? What does that mean? If last year
was a bad year, you want to kind of
normalize it. So with Val, that's
exactly what I'm going to do. I'm going
to do the terminal value calculation
now. But with VA, what's the problem I
face? It's a coal mining company, right?
or iron or mining company and iron ore
prices vary year to year. So if I take
the most recent year and happens to be a
really good year, I'm going to overvalue
the company. If I take the most recent
year, it's really bad. So I did I think
the common sense thing I averaged across
time. So I'm I'm going to use the
terminal value model today but with
numbers that I think they can sustain
forever. So in the case of Ali, here's
what I did. I started by looking at the
return on capital over a 5year period
because I know price had gone up and
down. The return capital is about
17.25%. I computed the cost of cap for
the company based on the bottom up beta.
So that should look familiar. And the
cost of capital I ended up with was
about
8.2%. So I've got my return on capital
of 17.25% cost of capital of 8.2%.
Already I have a story I need to tell.
Right? You have a return capital above
the cost of capital. If I'm going to
lock this in, I've got to talk about
what the competitive advantage is that
allows Valet to earn this. And with
commodity companies, the answer is
pretty simple. There's a limited amount
of commodity under the ground, oil. And
if you already have those reserves, you
have an advantage. You're a Ramco. Your
return on capital is not going to the
cost of capital now or forever because
you have those advantages to value the
company. I am going to go to a stable
growth model right away because I
believe this company's already mature.
So I look at the operating income 17.626
billion. I do have to pay taxes on that.
So bring in the tax rate and I subtract
from it how much I'll need to reinvest
to get my growth rate. My growth rate is
tiny. It's 2%. But to get that growth, I
still need to reinvest. And here I'm
going to go back to that sustainable
growth equation. Why? Because if you're
in steady state, things have settled in.
That's an implicit assumption. My growth
rate is 2%. My return on capital from
above is
17.25%. How much will I need to
reinvest? 2% divided by
17.25% is about
11.6%. I will need to reinvest about
11.6% of my after tax operating income
to deliver that growth rate. In a
minute, we'll stop and ask, what if I
don't think they can keep the 17.25%
return on capitalism?
My free cash flow to the firm is my
operating income after taxes and after
reinvestment. You divide by the cost of
capital 8.2% minus the growth rate. You
get a value for the operating assets of
about 203
billion. You value just the operating
assets. Why? Because you start with the
operating income and I have some mopping
up to do. I haven't valued cash. The
income from cash is not part of my
operating income. So I add cash. I'm
interested in the equity. So I subtract
out debt. The value of equity I get is
167 billion which if you divide by the
number of shares gives me a value per
share of almost
$32. Stock was trading at 13. Some of
you are going to face this on your
valuation in both directions. You're
going to come up with the value. It's
going to be very different than the
price. And there are three
possibilities, right? One is you're
wrong and the market is right. always
start with that as the starting
possibility. The second is you're right
and the market is wrong. An extremely
dangerous egoistic position to take. Or
the third, which I think is the most
reasonable one, is you're both wrong and
you hope you're less wrong than the
market is wrong. Why? Because you're
both trying to guess the future. I was a
little concerned about how big the
difference was. And what's driving this
is twofold. One is I took the operating
income over the last 5 years and the
return on capital and the return on
capital was
17.52% allowing me to get my growth with
very little
reinvestment. One reason the return on
capital was high for almost all
commodity companies in the first part of
the century between 2000 and 2015 was
China.
I know we blame China for pretty much
everything, but in this case, it was
Chinese infrastructure investment that
was driving up commodity prices. Iron
prices for the first decade, almost all
the way through 2013 were about two
times higher than they'd been in the
previous century because of Chinese
demand. I think I screwed up here. You
know where I screwed up? I took an
average over the five years when this
cycle is actually a 30 or a 40year
cycle. And if you take that cycle in,
IOR prices have a lot more downside on
them than I'm seeing by just looking at
this
period. I bought Val and I two years
later on on my blog I I bought Val as a
three as a bet on three things. A bet on
a commodity iron or a bet on a country.
Brazil was going through a bad time and
a bet on a currency. I called it my 3C
bet. And two years later, I wrote a post
called no mass no mass.
And I got this feedback from Brazilian
Portuguese saying, "That's Spanish, not
Portuguese." And I said, "You're missing
the point." And I said, "I screwed up. I
screwed up on valet because I I clearly
underestimated how much downside there
was to iron or
prices. But there's no point to regret,
right? I made a mistake. You move on."
And I learned from that. When I value
commodity companies now, I look at
longer cycles because otherwise I think
you can end up overestimating numbers.
But I did use a state. I would still use
a stable growth model, but my numerator
then would probably be a lower operating
income and a a much lower return on
capital than what I used in this
valuation. So, can you use a stable
growth model right away? Absolutely.
About third of all companies are
probably ready for a stable growth
model. Just make sure you look at the
numbers and make sure those because
those numbers once you put them in there
get locked in forever.
So now I'm ready to put the bow on
Disney because we've talked about Disney
all the way through the class. Let's
talk about valuing Disney. I did give
Disney 10 years of growth. But before
you freak out, it's not really high
growth. It's growth that's higher than
the growth rate of the economy. For the
next five years, I assume the status
quo. What does that mean? I assume that
Bob Iger would continue to run the firm
and that he'd continue to run the firm
the way he'd run it. So I locked in the
existing numbers. So let's go down. The
tax rate was 31% was their effective tax
rate. The marginal tax rate then was
36%. The return capital was 12.6%. I'm
going to assume they can continue to
earn 12.6% for the next 5
years. Their reinvestment rate was 54%
including acquisitions. I'm assuming
that because the existing management is
continuing to run the firm that that 54%
would stay roughly the same. Your return
capital and reinvestment rate stay the
same. Your growth rate becomes a product
of those two numbers. Reinvestment rate
times return capital. So I'm giving them
growth but 6.8% growth for the next 5
years. Higher than stable growth but not
25 30
35%. For their cost of capital I left
their debt ratio at 11 and a so if you
remember right now the debt ratio is
about 11 and a half%. I left it there.
But when we did the optimal capital
structure, didn't we decide that Disney
could go up to 40%. So why am I not
changing the debt ratio to 40%. Analysts
often do this. They call this using a
target debt ratio. Why am I not doing
it? Is I'm not running the company. Bob
Iger is. And I can't just replace debt
ratio with the debt ratio that I think
they should have because I'm not making
that choice. I think they will continue
to stay at a low debt ratio. And they
might have lots of good reasons and some
bad reasons for it. So their existing
cost of capital, their existing return
on capital, their existing reinvestment
rate all get locked in for the next 5
years. You're saying what happens after
year five? I start to close the tap and
start moving towards stable growth. But
remember in my spreadsheet, I'm in year
six. I'm feeling completely
lost. What will 2029 look like? I don't
even know what 2025 will look like. I'm
really at that point in time where I
say, I don't know what's going to
happen. So, I'm going to do something
very strange because I'm uncertain about
year six, I'm going to jump to year
11. What happens in year 11? I assume
that Disney becomes a mature company.
Let's play it out. If it becomes a
mature company, the first thing that's
going to happen, its growth rate has to
become a growth rate. It can sustain
forever. The growth rate I ended up
using was 2.5% a year in perpetuity.
That was a little below my risk-free
rate. 2.75% was my risk-free rate. So my
argument is it's a mature company is
going to grow at 2 and a half%. Remember
this is year 11 2 and a half%. My growth
rate for the next 5 years is
6.8%. I still need your six year 7 year.
What's the easiest way to get from 6.8
to
2.5? I took the difference divide by
five. Don't finesse
this. Hey, the big drivers are your
starting and your ending points. You can
take linear steps. If you want to be
mathematic, you can do log linear. I
don't care. Get from 6.8 to 2.5% and do
it in a way where you're not sitting
there in your six and seven and 8 trying
to do it yourself. Years 6 through 10
become my transition period. All they're
there for is to get me from where I am
now, which can be 8 10 15% growth down
to 2 3 4% growth. And I'm doing it in
steps. So my growth rate drops. Will my
return on capital come under pressure as
well as as I become a mature company? I
think so. In some companies, if you're
an airline or a steel company, they will
move towards the cost of capital. So
there the return cap here, I'm going to
leave the return on capital above the
cost of capital at 10%. Above the cost
of capital and my story will be Disney's
brand name is not going away after year
10. It will continue to earn more than
the cost of
capital. My cost of capital which starts
at 7.81% 81% I do move to a 20% debt
ratio. Why just to 20? Because clearly
this management is conservative on
borrowing money. They're going to
continue to run the
company. With each of the assumptions,
you can see that I'm making a leap of
faith. I'm making a I'm coming up with a
story and essentially I'm I have to
justify the story and the only person I
have to justify it is to myself because
my money is writing on this. It's not
about convincing other people. I'm not
this is not a debate society. We say
convince me. Why would I need to
convince you it's your money you
convince yourself and in this case
that's basically what I'm what you see
playing out. So those are the things
that are going to happen. And as those
things
happen I'm also going to make sure that
my terminal value I follow the rules.
First my growth rate in in stable growth
is set below the risk rate. So this is
my checkbox as I go through a DCF. If I
look at your growth rate in perpetuity,
check your risk-free rate. Okay. Check.
Second, I do assume in steady state that
my excess returns come down. They don't
go to zero. And my story is that the
brand name will persist. The 10% return
on capital that they will earn. It's
still higher than the 7.29% but not by
as much as it was in the high growth
period. Third, just because your growth
rate comes down doesn't mean you can
stop reinvesting. One of the biggest
mistakes I see in terminal value
calculations is many analysts say my
company is a stable growth company. It's
growing at the inflation rate.
Therefore, my capex can be set equal to
depreciation. I don't need any
reinvestment. No, that's not going to
fly. If you have to grow even at the
inflation rate, you have to reinvest and
I make sure I reinvest enough by taking
my growth rate and dividing it my by my
return on capital. So, I'm reinvesting
about 25% of my after tax operating wood
updating my theme. So, even if I'm not
growing as a company, I need to keep my
theme parks updated. They'll start to
fall apart. That's a 25% reinvestment
rate. And I do lower my cost of capital
to make it a mature
company. Is this an upbeat story? I
think it is as upbeat as I could get in
2014. Will the story change over time?
Absolutely. Think about telling the
story for Disney today, right? Very
different company in a business that's
broken, the entertainment business. and
anybody doing entertainment companies
you see this play out in the numbers
it's broken because Netflix broke it
broke that basic way in which companies
used to make money and Disney used to be
a master at the old way so they feel the
pain so today valuing the company
different story different inputs
potentially different value but the
price has changed as well so those are
the assumptions and if you play them out
no they'll give you a value for the
operating assets but before we look at
that final
valuation. A couple of loose ends you
might have to tie up. I've talked about
three different ways you can get a value
for your equity. One is to discount
dividends at your cost of equity. And
that's easy. You do the discounting, you
get the present value, you're done.
That's your value of equity. The second
is you can discount free cash flow
equity. The cost of equity, the present
value is usually the value of the entire
equity. If you have options, and we'll
talk about why they might come into
play, you might have to worry about
what's the value of equity per share for
me as a common stockholder. But when you
take free cash flow of the firm at
discounted the cost of capital, which
we've done, there's a lot of loose ends
to tie
up. When you do free cash for the firm,
remember we start with operating income,
right? So, you valued only those items
that go into operating income. I'm not
being mysterious, but anything that's
not part of your operating income hasn't
been valued yet. One is cash, obviously.
That's why if you're valing Apple, you
got to add the 200 billion or Bxer Haway
300 or 150 200 250
billion. But you also haven't valued
holdings you have in other companies
which are called minority holdings. 5%
of another company, 8% of another
company. Disney for their Hong Kong
theme park owned a minority stake 49%
because the Chinese government insisted
that they be given 51%.
The Hong Kong theme park numbers don't
show up in operating income. So if you
have to value Disney, you got to bring
in the value of that minority stake into
your valuation. That's a loose end.
You're valuing a family group company.
God help you. You think you're done, but
they have 35 cross holdings. You got to
bring them in because you haven't valued
them
yet. Then you subtract out debt. You get
a value for the equity. And if you do
have options outstanding, and you know
what options I'm talking about, these
are options given to managers. there
another claim on your equity. This is
your last chance to clean up for it.
There's a reason you want to be sure you
bring in the things you want to clean up
for because after there after you come
up with the value of equity per share,
you're going to act on that number. Lots
of loose ends, but they're not
complicated. Just have to be detail
oriented. The spreadsheet asks you, you
know, what's your if you have minority
holdings, check the balance sheet. There
are minority holdings, they will be
there, but if you don't find them, don't
be surprised. Many companies, especially
US companies, don't have minority
holdings. Don't go looking for things
that don't exist because you'll waste a
lot of time. That's the basic process
for cleaning up. And with that in place,
there's my Disney November
2013 valuation. Every number in the
spreadsheet, I can trace back to a
session we've already done. Right? Let's
start at the bottom. My risk-free rate
is 2.75%. Derek, remind me again, what's
that risk- free rate coming from?
the US Treasury. And why am I looking at
the US Treasury? Because I'm doing my
valuation in US dollars. I chose to do
my valuation in US dollars. That goes
back to the risk-free rate session. Your
risk-free rate is based on my bait is
1.0013.
Suspiciously
precise, but that is the bottom up beta
based on the five businesses. Go back
and check page 76 of the first packet.
somewhere in there, right? My equity
risk premium of 5.76% reflecting
France the the equity risk premium that
reflects where Disney operates. 82% of
the US, 18% foreign, it's in there. That
gives me a cost of equity. The cost of
debt, I start with the same risk-free
rate. That's always the rule. I had a
default spread based on the actual
rating for Disney. And if I hadn't had
an actual rating, I'd gone with a
synthetic rating. I multiply by one
minus the marginal tax rate. Why
marginal? Because interest saves you tax
of the margin. And the weights are
market value including leases then
because I had to do it explicitly. 88
12% equity 11 12% debt. There's my cost
of capital. That's the cost of capital
we came up with in section one of this
class when we looked at invest. The same
hurdle rate we used in capital budgeting
is now become my cost of capital. So
that's below the line. Go above the
line. My reinvestment rate, my return on
in capital. My reinvestment rate comes
in the capital budgeting section. The
projects you've taken drive your
reinvestment rate. The theme parks, the
movies, 54%. My return on capital
reflects the fact that Disney has done
this pretty well. They've earned more
than the cost of capital. My growth rate
comes from those
numbers. You project out the cash flows.
Basically, I let the uh the operating
income grow 6.8% a year. I subtract 54%
of it every year as reinvestment. Notice
I've consolidated. I could add I could
do net cap exchange but ultimately
everything comes out. So I've
consolidated. I've got my free cash to
the firm and over time the growth rate
starts to decrease but my reinvestment
also goes down. When your growth goes
down comes with a bonus. You have to
reinvest less. So my cash flows pick up
over time and I put closure in year 10
by making Disney a mature
company. The end game of the story is
you discount the cash flows back. you
get a value of about 125 billion for the
value of the operating assets. Much of
that value comes in the terminal value
and I'm not going to be defensive about
it. That's exactly what I would expect.
That's where you make money as an equity
investor. Added cash which is right off
the balance sheet and in the balance
sheet they did show that Hong Kong
investment. I also think they have an
investment in an Indian TV company which
is a minority holding. So there I
trusted the accountants which makes me a
little nervous but there was no basis
for me to kind of replace that. So I to
added that on I subtract that and I did
subtract out minority interest. What's
minority interest? What's which side of
the balance sheet would you usually see
minority interest? I think it's also
called noncontrolling interest. It's you
on the asset side of the liability side.
Liability side. What does it reflect?
The fact that accountants consolidate,
I've never understood this to be quite
honest. When you own 60% of a company,
what do accountants ask you to act like
you own? 100%. Right? And at the last
moment, they wake up and say, "But you
own only 60%." Say, "That's what I've
been trying to tell you all this time.
You don't own 40%."
Duh. And then you take that minority
interest. That's the value of the 40%
that doesn't belong to you because you
overcount it. And Disney does have a
controlling interest in again a couple
of companies. This is the minority
interest. I'm subtracting out saying
I've added too
much. There are some options. Not a huge
number. In the case of Disney, you know
what kinds of companies that number can
be a huge number? Young technology
company. When I valued Amazon in 2000,
20% of my equity value went away because
management options had been given out so
freely. Why am I taking them out?
Because as a common stockholder, when a
company pays with options, it's paying
with my money. Options are not free
currency. Something again companies
forgot in the
'90s. Subtract it out. We come up with a
value per share of
$62.56. We I should take the we I this
is my story, so I'll take ownership of
it. 6256. And when you value a publicly
traded company, you're always two
questions away from being exposed as a
fraud, right?
publicly traded company. So when you
value per share, what's the first thing
you
check? You check the price per share,
right? And if the price per share is
lower than the value, what's the
follow-up question you need to ask to
figure out whether I believe my own
valuation? Do you buy? And what are the
three answers I can give
you? No. In which case, it's a nice
number crunching exercise, but I don't
have enough faith in the numbers to
actually act on it. Yes. and lie. You
have no way of checking or yes and buy.
In this case, those choices were taken
out because the stock was actually
trading at about
6771. Not far enough that I'm going to
freak out and say it's massively
overvalued, but it's a stock that
is at least slightly
overvalued. Disney's flirted between
being under and overvalued. There was a
brief period, I think two years ago,
when it got beaten up badly where it
dropped enough it was undervalued. Now
it's close to fairly valued. There is no
decision that's going to be permanent,
right? Something can be undervalued
right now and become overvalued later,
especially in periods like the last few
months where prices jump
around. That value though comes from a
whole host of assessments we made about
Disney all the way through the
class. So that's the value per share you
get.
And in many ways I could teach this
class in reverse starting with that
page. Don't worry I'm not going to do it
because everything in that page can be
traced back to those three big
principles in corporate finance right
the investment decision the financing
decision the dividend decision. Where
does the investment decision show up? It
shows up in two places in your
reinvestment rate through the projects
you take and your return on capital and
whether you took good projects. Where
does your financing decision show up in
your cost of capital? Where does your
dividend decision show up? Again,
through the reinvestment rate. You want
to pay more in dividends, you will
reinvest less and have lower growth.
Ultimately, all these numbers trace back
to what companies do on investing,
financing, and dividend decisions. So,
this is the same valuation presented in
terms of here are the the way. So,
everything we did in this class
ultimately flows through into the
assumptions that drive
value. But along the way, we've also
highlighted some things that Disney
could do differently, right? Like
what at least in the case of Disney,
it's taking good project. But you could
have a company where you're internal
capitalist and the cost of capital. Say
if I ran the company, I would do things
differently. I want you to put ego hat
on again. Say, I'm going to
run Caba Cheesecake Factory. What would
I do differently? First, you might
revisit your reinvest your reinvestment
policy and say, should I reinvest more?
Should I be opening more restaurants?
Should I be opening better restaurants?
So, that's going to be one of the thing.
Second is you look at your financing
mix. Maybe you can borrow more and lower
your cost of
capital. Or third, you can think about
the competitive advantages you have as a
company. Say, can I make those
advantages stronger? It's going to show
up both in the length of your growth
period and how much you earn over and
above your cost of capital. All
restructuring again flows through one or
more of these numbers.
I'm going to put my ego hat on, say if I
ran Disney, what would I do differently?
At the minimum, I'd get them to use a
little more debt right away. Right?
So, that's basically it's just a very
preliminary attempt at what I would do
differently. So, one is I'd perhaps
reinvest less and try to earn because
Disney's return capital used to be
higher, but they had kind of gone into
more capital intensive businesses. So I
said maybe you can earn a higher return
capital and reinvest a little less.
You're reinvesting too much. That pushes
their growth rate from 6.8 to 7%. Not a
huge growth because it is a company
that's reasonably wellrun. I did change
their debt ratio to 40% debt. Where did
that come from? At this point in the
class I can point to my optimal capital
structure and say if you go to that 40%
your cost of capital is much
lower. So slightly different
reinvestment policy, fairly different
financing policy. You play it through.
The value per share I get is
74.91. What was it before I made the
change? 62. I'm getting 74 if I make
these. What should I call that
difference? That's the value of
control. If you have a company that's
already perfectly managed and perfectly
run and you look at every input say I
wouldn't change that. I wouldn't change
that. The values are going to be the
same. Right? Invidia you might say, hey,
Jensen Wong is about as good a man as
you can get for the company. I can't
change anything about the company. The
value control can be
zero. But if you're a company that's
abysmally run where you look at
dimension after dimension, I would do
things differently. You can get a value
of control that can be
100%. Now bankers might use 20% as a
rule of thumb, but you can see very
quickly it'll depend on your company.
And I'm not going to ask you to do this
in your company, but you have the the
ingredients to do it, right? Because you
assess the capital structure each stage.
You were saying if I ran the company,
this is what I would do differently. And
this allows you to take all those
things, put them into evaluation, said
if you did all of this, this is what
will happen to your value.
Can we can I go first? Wait a second.
Guys on Zoom, I think you might need to
mute your microphone.
So remember this
page has the muting happening,
right? page we started with. We're back.
So, as I read this page, which I read in
the first session, I want you to put
some flesh on the words because you're
now ready, right? What's the endgame in
in in in corporate finance? To maximize
the value of the
business. The investment principle, what
does it say? When you go out and make
investments, make sure you earn a return
on those investments that exceeds a
minimum acceptable hurdle rate. What's
the minimum acceptable hurdle rate?
You're a publicly traded company. It
comes from looking at equity through the
eyes of a diversified investor measuring
a cost of equity and your debt comes
from your default risk. The risk there
is captured by either default risk or a
beta and it shows up as a cost of
capital. How do we measure returns?
Based on cash flows. Remember the Disney
theme park incremental cash flows. You
take the present value of the cash flows
time weighted. And when there are side
effects, we try to bring them into the
cash flows rather than talk about them
afterwards.
Then you have the financing principle.
Basically says when you go out and
borrow money, find a mix of debt and
equity that minimizes your hurdle rate.
Went through that process. It ask you
what kind of debt should you take? Try
to match your debt up your assets. If
you long-term debt, use long long-term
assets, use long-term debt. Dollar
assets, use dollar debt. And the
dividend principle basically says if you
cannot find investments to take with
those cash flows, return the cash back
to the investors. And there I'm not
going to be dogmatic. If you're a
company I trust and you want to hold the
cash, I'm going to say I'm okay with
that. But if I don't trust you, then I
think I'm on fair ground saying, "Hey,
this is my cash. Give me back the cash."
As to the choice between dividends and
buybacks, it's not categorical either.
One's not better than the other. They're
just different ways of returning cash.
And if your clientele likes dividends, I
see nothing wrong with paying a special
dividend, increasing dividends. But if
your clientele is younger, doesn't want
that dividend to be taxed, then I think
buying back stock makes more sense for
you. At the end of this process, even if
you never go into, if you remember this
page, it's going to help you no matter
what role you have in business. You're
in marketing strategy. This is the big
picture of running. This is not a
corporate finance picture. This is a bit
a big business. It's a business picture
of how of the different ingredients are
the ingredients connected to each other.
You take more investments, you got to
come up with more funding. So investing
and financing. You pay out more debt, it
you can't pay as much in div. So
basically every one of these decisions
flows into the other one. That's why the
whole thing hangs together. So you can't
say I I get investing but I don't get
financing and dividends because it's all
or nothing almost in terms of
understanding how they hang together. So
on Monday when we come back I'm going to
take your numbers that you will be
turning into me on Sunday and I'm going
to take you through kind of a review of
the class using your numbers to kind of
make that review. So we're going to talk
about what betas look like across your
companies, what the returns look like
across your companies, what Jensen's
alphas your companies delivered and I
need and what percent of your companies
are under know whether they pay out but
I need your numbers to be able to do
that. So try to get them in by Sunday.
In fact, I think five points of your
grade do go with the submission of those
numbers. So we'll talk to you on Monday.